good morning John trilobites are super
weird and I want you to know more about
them it's easy to forget that the moment
we live in is just this one snapshot of
this huge history of life on Earth and
yeah we have to and should and do study
now but also there's a lot to learn if
we look at the past and it can just be
fascinating as well which is why we've
teamed up with PBS Digital Studios to
make a news show
it's called Aeons and it's about the
entire history of life on Earth so if
most biology as what's happening right
now
eons is everything else all of the life
that has happened so far until now turns
out there's lots of good stuff to cover
here our first episode is about
trilobite of course the emergence of
trial beds happened around 500 million
ish years ago it was part of what's
called the Cambrian explosion where life
on Earth got way more complex they were
the first true arthropods arthropods now
take up three-quarters of the world's
species so basically good Anya trilobite
arthropods basically are the segmented
exoskeleton covered things that you see
all around you right now spiders
butterflies millipedes crabs like those
things too even though horseshoe crabs
share some family resemblance with
trilobite and some horseshoe crab
species did coexist with trilobite s'
they are old horseshoe crabs the last
species of trilobite s' went extinct
around 250 million years ago but even
though they did not last forever they
were extremely successful they existed
for 270 million years rhyme mates for
comparison have existed for around 50
million years so we have a lot of
catching up to do we found trilobite
fossils on every continent and described
over 15,000 species one of the weird
reasons why travela bites are so well
studied and why we find so many of them
is that most trilobite fossils aren't
actually trilobite it's nice being an
organism whose skin grows with them but
that is not the case for arthropods if
an arthropod wants to grow it has to
shed its exoskeleton and then move out
of that old house that was too small for
it and when it does that it leaves
behind that shed exoskeleton which then
can fossil eyes and that happened a lot
obviously with trilobite so the majority
of trilobite fossils aren't the organism
that died there the shed exoskeleton
which of course we can still use to date
the trilobite and to figure out what
kind it was and learn more about the
species
bunch of reasons trilobite s-- were
probably so successful there was strong
exoskeletons there jointed legs but they
also this pretty big deal had the first
complex eyes and trilobite eyes are
freaking awesome some of them have
thousands of individual lenses and the
lenses are made of calcite they're a
crystal like the trilobite grew crystals
in its eyes our eye lenses they can flex
and change size so if I look at
something close-up I focus on it I look
at something far away I focus on that
then the lenses in my eyes are actually
changing shape if your lens is made of
rock that's hard to do you also end up
with a problem that astronomers had in
the 17th century which is that you get
weird distortions unless you use very
specific lens shapes in the 1600s two
astronomers came up with two different
lens shapes that helped to fix this
problem here's the one that Christian
Huygens came up with and here's the one
that Rene Descartes came up with yes
that Rene Descartes he did a lot of
stuff and here are the islands shapes
for the travel abite pros an abscess and
the trilobite dominant tonight this is
so dang cool right these lens shapes
allowed for objects to be in focus when
they were pretty close up or pretty far
away and also got rid of some of that
lens distortion it took humans 300
million years to catch up with trilobite
evolution I just love it and if you want
to learn more about trilobite our first
episode is up youtube.com slash Ian's
where me Blake and Callie will be taking
you through the entire history of life
on Earth it's gonna be fun join us there
John I'll see you on Tuesday